je m'appelle samantha jackson d'être
très heureux après ouais on voit ce
qu'ils puissent qui est bien je trouve
que comme la première fois c'est que la
première fois qu'on voit c'est l'ourse
qui parle donc là ce truc là à mettre en
place
et là encore une fois il ya une idée
assez forte s'il ne seront plus il veut
se marier quoi je vous déclare ours en
peluche ces femmes vous pouvez embrasser
d'ours
comme quoi les américains se fiche
royalement de tout c'est toujours ce fut
cette espèce de francs par année
c'est vachement vif c'est un problème
bah j'ai pas envie d'avoir un avocat qui
chante les chansons de la reine des
neiges à la barre voilà c'est
complètement loufoque et c'est ce qu'il
fonctionne aussi fois qu'ils refusent
les droits fondamentaux uniquement parce
qu'elle est différente
il ya un message un peu plus comme on
faisait un peu plus soutenue
déjà c'est intéressant engagé un avocat
et on poursuit le gouvernement pour
atteinte aux droits civiques je trouve
qu'il ya vraiment une progression et que
tout a évolué n'est pas juste dans la
chambre est tous ou dans les changes
gratuit quoi ça va toujours quelque part
quoi même là il ya certaines choses qui
sont placés qui sont acer ainsi
intelligible intelligent core du coup ce
que tu fais tu me prépares comment ça tu
prépares tu fais quoi avec ta main je me
prépare comme sage entrée directe en
valais ce que tu te crois dans une
soirée mousse il a un rythme et
décadence quantique coty tchatche ça va
très très vite quoi condamner
spéculation oui didier plaidoiries ont
mené dans mon cabinet un but plus et je
dirais trop être avocat ben vous faut le
jouer faut que tout soit en place
voilà quoi c'est quoi votre deuxième
prénom messi et ben voilà donc vous êtes
sans l jackson dial comme samuel jackson
c'est qui
sans dec vous n'allez jamais au cinéma
seynois certaines choses qui dit c'est
ouais ça si je suis suivi de le faire
pour quelqu'un comme moi quant au chien
un language association générale je
compte photo je la pose sur facebook
hashtag dit demain mes fils par exemple
quand tu leur demande leur avis et non
bah c'est toi quoi sa collègue race est
du grand art curieusement sur le premier
mois je pensais que c'était un truc
réservé à aux adultes enfin certaines
catégories de l'adulte est en fait je me
suis rendu compte que
la tête dans le guidon faut rentrer à
fond dedans puis surtout les gars moi ce
qui leur plaît cedex adipique à tabou
excusez le sumo petit garçon cinq ans
brutus assieds toi moi j'étais nuggets
j'aime pas les nuggets pense que c'est
bien la mener ces voilà quoi il est
complètement déluré donc de fait même
même pour un gamin la lecture à
l'évidente quoi tu prêtes on leur dit
wave asie j'y vois pas qu'est ce qui
fait une avalanche de poigne et elle n'a
que y'a des mecs sains michaud